the Joe Rogan experience well that's
also argument for team Trump I mean
that's Trump's argument is what he's
doing is he's boosting up business in
the United States and whether or not you
love him or hate him what he's doing is
having a positive net effect on the
global economy particularly United
States economy and that's gonna make us
stronger I mean this is whether you love
him or hate him you've got to look at
that objectively and go okay well is
there any merit to what he's saying well
I don't understand economics I don't I
just trust people that study it I don't
have the time but they're saying yes in
some ways he's doing things that benefit
business I think that I think that the
the trouble with the approach that Trump
has taken you know he obviously he's got
his schtick and he's got the things that
he's got his talking points the things
that he says but he is continuing this
mentality when we look at like the trade
war with China and you know the trade
conflict that he started with Canada and
now with different European countries it
is it's the the zero-sum mentality that
in order for us and our economy and our
people to win then the people or the
economies of these other countries have
to suffer and that's what I agree with
what you just said Jocko about you know
building a strong helping grow a strong
global economy gosh shared prosperity I
mean you look at the opportunity that
would provide for peace and less
conflict rather than what we're seeing
it and that this is playing out in real
time with China right now where you see
this trade war that is escalating a
tariff or that's escalating I have met
with farmers in Iowa who are hurting
tremendously because of this trade and
tariff or farm manufacturers small
business owners and the danger of this
continuing to grow and continuing to
escalate an economic war can very easily
turn into a hot war and again we're
talking about a nuclear-armed country
where these ever escalating tensions
push us closer and closer to the brink
of of nuclear catastrophe something
nuclear strategists are saying that we
are we are closer to now than then at
least in a generation I think this is
where
the foreign policy that I'm that I'm
putting forward to the American people
that I will lead with is one that is
focused on on engaging with other
countries being that force for good
focusing on cooperation rather than
conflict in every respect being able to
work out yeah we do have trade
differences with China there's no
question about that but being able to do
so in a way that is not further pushing
us closer and closer to the brink of a
hot war and potentially disastrous can
you get into what is the trade what is
the issue with China like what what is
Trump feels like we don't have a fair
deal right that's what he's stated I
think that there I think his his
diagnosis I think is correct I think
that's widely accepted there's you know
ongoing trade imbalance with China and
some of the issues with with IP theft I
think those are the top two that that
come to the forefront the problem is not
with the diagnosis of the issue it is
how he's going about it in a very you
know shoot-from-the-hip kind of way I
mean he's like almost conducting his
negotiations via Twitter he's got
negotiators who were sitting across from
the Chinese and hey okay we're getting
closer to a deal we're gonna work this
out then all of a sudden something goes
out on Twitter they're like whoa man
like the whole thing just changed which
you know it's it's may be funny when
when Trump is putting out something with
Trump Tower in Greenland but when there
are such real consequences to the
day-to-day lives of the American people
and when we're pushing us closer and
closer to the brink of a nuclear
catastrophe escalating these tensions
with countries like China and with
Russia this is I mean it's it's serious
the stakes are very high and and so this
is this is more about how Trump is doing
this in such an irresponsible way that's
creating destabilization and uncertainty
both with our economy and also in our
relationships with other countries
it's everything that made him famous as
a businessman all the brashness all the
shooting from the hip yes the idea that
everybody thought that he was gonna
change when he got in the White House is
hilarious the guy's 73 oh I actually you
can laugh at me then because I thought
well he got elected I was like okay well
this is gonna be interesting to see him
you know
become presidential and and then like
whatever one day interview said another
tweet about somebody else like Rosie
O'Donnell's opinion yeah exactly so
crazy but but he's but what that means
is he's unpredictable
right and so he's the guy in the bar
that you look at you're like well I'm
just gonna give that guy a little extra
clearance cuz he looks like he's crazy
right so I think that might be what he
either thinks he's doing yeah or or not
but here's the interesting thing about
this okay you know I I don't want to
quote numbers on these things because
I'm not sure what they are right now but
I got a factory been made we make
clothes we make jeans we make jiu-jitsu
geez all right all made in America
from the cotton that's grown in America
it's a woven we weave it in our factory
we're doing everything here now there's
things like labor labor is more
expensive in America because we pay our
workers because they're they're awesome
and and so it costs a little bit more to
build the product if you have a Chinese
company that can make a jiu-jitsu key
and they have they're paying their
workers a dollar a day literally and
then they can ship that guy over here
well then they can beat us on the price
now their quality is not as good but
they can beat us on the price and
someone goes okay well I can pay you
know 70 bucks for this Chinese ski or a
hundred bucks for this American game
okay I'm gonna buy the Chinese one in 70
bucks so and this actually this part
happened again I the details I can't
quite remember but they said hey we're
not gonna put a tariff on DS coming into
America because they can't be made here
because they can't be made here and
guess what specific to specific Wow it
was like okay
can't be many can't be made here and it
was actually pretty true when was this
I don't know I don't know again I'm I'm
stepping out on a Ledge here gonna have
my buddy Pete come on this podcast we're
here forever though no they haven't been
him they've been made in Pakistan in
China and there was one company that was
making down in Brazil but we said no
actually they can't be made here and
were make them here and they put a seven
percent tariff on G's from overseas and
so now that kind of equalizes the price
are just a little bit more expensive but
it's made in American it's higher
quality so people say okay well buy a
mirror are you the only company in
America nobody's company in America that
is making American companies they're
buying them over 600% yep
know that you know yeah and what's the
key company just so everybody knows it's
called its origin origin main calm
[Applause]